i hate this one like i just can't do it
oh i'm gonna have a strap just like we
have never done something like this on
the channel before it's not even that
crazy
but to me it is we've got a few
different people in the discord chat
um and we're all gonna play four guys
together
but yeah i will let them introduce
themselves to you
okay so hi braden hello
hi we have a mr
tetsubin
hey sidnator hi bob
did you just call me mum i was not ready
for that what am i involved in what kind
of screen is this is a family affair
i'm never ready to be a mum hi mom
i just had a nature's mom hey mom
oh no i was talking about me and my
screaming
all right
what's the um dive button oh okay eggs
but whatever works in your head you just
do it yeah mind tightly
oh no i'm going oh [ __ ] why did i do
that why did i do that
i could see him i can't lose on the
first
one yeah hopefully we all get qualified
no no
no no no no no no i already thought
[ __ ] i am stuck
i am doing really bad far people have
done i'm doing
not excuse me someone just pushed me off
number
oh this is bad who is i
i i only assume brayden's done right
yeah
i knew it i knew
are you one of them guys that is first
and just um wait until everyone gets
close
well i'm playing better than i am right
now
i'm definitely not gonna make it two
people
two space one space no
oh no i didn't make it oh
no that was a bad position oh there's a
freaking superhero like mint
it's a mint with a superhero cape ah
does it
oh i'm with you now it looks like a mint
right yeah right
you thought you were like oh it's a
superhero mint or top right top right
top right right it's like a spearmint
top right top right is an owl for me oh
is it different on every client nothing
i think it's instanced
yeah yeah two seconds oh though
we had to kill him we had three for a
moment
i know that was i hate that one
yes now i get to play again
[Laughter]
i mean no no i'm sorry guys oh really
room for you
you're so close
[Laughter]
i want you to stay on that platform yeah
they're like you are mine and mine alone
what do you mean your youtuber
just face how you're doing on like how
close to burning you are yeah
right
have you ever done it though no don't no
[ __ ]
i've never done it either never
i think it might actually be impossible
no is that
oh my god oh [ __ ] out i thought
oh no no i'm here
oh jesus christ come on i made it
i made it i made it yeah i've made it
thank you for the follow manzo so i
appreciate it thanks for following
hey man i don't have a stream so i'm
just gonna echo you guys
what what does that mean what does jinx
mean first template
changed this is a hard one i think
you've got to run away from the heart
person
we're all blue what what are we doing
this way
how many are there oh there's two of
them i'm gonna hide
no no no no no no oh crap there's i'm
all there
i'm just kidding everybody like what the
hell is happening
i think i can't find anyone without it
we did it how oh my god thank you so
much gaming with malachi hippo
character with a pink hat flips it
backwards and raises his thumb up in the
air
because i read a restream chat it
doesn't it doesn't translate emotes or
like gifts so it just explains to you
what it is
so i just read it
[Laughter]
i thought i thought malakai was playing
with us and they were telling
us like what character they were like a
character with a pink hat
oh my god oh this one requires a lot of
four girls
oh [ __ ] now
okay i am in the
i don't think i have too many young
people on this street
uh below 16. love swearing it
it was at this moment that he has been
new she [ __ ] up with a swearing agent
how the hell did you do this one oh you
jump got it
are we all dead oh of course
[Applause]
okay he's gonna get hit by the balls
the animation was new you like running
like you had purpose it was insane yeah
i know
[Music]
victory was so close it was it was so
close braden put your socks up come on
i don't know why i've been given this
crown of like
this because you are the best at this
that's just what the best of this would
say
but if not one
come on come on come on come on come on
come on
right back
[Laughter]
i can't help you
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on
you rolled you really rolled
dug and rolled oh crap that's the wrong
way oh someone just you didn't
[ __ ] [ __ ] no
come on i feel sorry if that
three-year-old that's watching
yeah you feel like ham
don't repeat anything
come on already
[Laughter]
oh i'm crying a little bit
why are you scared yeah
i just get very like intense and then
like my eyes start
to walk it works
uh wait hello okay this is
actually quite scary i've got a bag over
there
[Music]
[ __ ] people
yeah what happened you're not in
no i wouldn't i was just on the line
no this was supposed to be the game that
we won
all of us collectively oh yeah yeah
guys oh [ __ ] hell [ __ ] out of
banana
i'd have to follow him sorry
wow so it is really fun
yeah they are very they're very good
they know how to play up their funniness
i didn't make it
that was really hard i've never done
that one before oh perfect
so you can join for next game then
that's great
yes if i get it installed soon and then
uh
i have no other issues braden how are
you so like chill
it doesn't taste like this is so chill
you can see i'm coming
you hardly move everyone else is just
going crazy you just stood there doing
nothing
i just didn't float dude yeah bro
i haven't won that's life
oh wow are we going
again
[Applause]
oh i'm timed out
connection braden you're gone too
yeah oh that is the worst way for me to
live
oh i'm so sorry that's shitty
oh man i can't believe what happened
all right well that is me i'm sorry to
leave on such a donut but
i've had a wonderful time thank you so
much for inviting me yeah it's been
super fun
yeah definitely um i'll put in the
discord like whenever
i'm gonna do it again and then hopefully
you can join too
okay yeah cactus lightning
okay let's do it then guys my
item choice helpful i brought my sock at
this already
yeah it's hectic don't worry it takes a
long time to get used to i'm still
getting used to it
brandon's like pro but i'm not [ __ ]
he's playing he's playing way many more
games than i have that makes sense way
many more
and i've still had her called never mind
you're on the network oh i didn't get
through yeah eliminated
no one got through i did of course
someone in chat said i like beans i
think that's very valid
brilliant epic epic nugget their name is
so
cool
now do you like beans on look at it
small oh
that's a question for
oh you beans with nuggets
oh yeah yeah
i won't go further i'm behind the cactus
person
used up on the right side the answer is
40.
[Music]
no
i killed the dinosaur oh for [ __ ] sake
did you make it no
15.
i'm so close i'm so nice i'm so nice i'm
so bad
yes nice wait are we
who else who else
right this is just like whatever
that just pushed sorry oh no
i think we're all together right now
well at least i'm with someone
oh no i don't think i've made it people
in front of me
yes oh no
wait i'm not lost
it was so hot last week though i
couldn't fall asleep until i had a cold
shower at night
so in order to uh you need to grab one
with the you have to keep your tail
or grab a tail yeah keep your tail there
if you can
and if you dive okay
turn off people's spawn with tails right
yeah yeah okay don't take my tail
this is my tail what number are you yes
[ __ ] i can't see anything oh no my
tail
i don't know i can't i have
there's so many people here trying to
grab the same tail
oh
five eliminated yet oh get up get up get
up oh [ __ ] up
ah so um every time you step on a tile
it's going to disappear so you just want
to try and stay on the tiles because
you'll end up just getting to the bottom
and dying so just try and stay on a tile
right well jump to like another tile but
stay on the block of tiles if that makes
sense
i get it yeah yeah so yeah a lot of
people go for the outsides
still alive well there's three people on
your level
uh i can't look up
[Music]
oh crap oh
last one yep let's see how we do
all right sorry no we're dead by there
like ah
come on come on get up get up you stupid
little cactus
oh [ __ ] this come on guys get to the
edge so i can [ __ ] jump
oh no i'm doing terrible i've just
looked behind but i am dead last
oh my god oh my god stop pushing me
you're quite high pitched there yeah i'm
sorry i turned into like a
rat when i play this game oh god
god guys stop it please
excuse me there's loads of dogs outside
your window now no
what sorry
i speak [ __ ] whistling i wish if there
was something
i would not be a happy girl right now
i've made it
oh no how did i do that how the [ __ ]
no
[Music]
i hate this one like i just can't do it
oh i'm gonna have a strap just like
okay uh yeah thanks everyone for
watching and thanks you guys
for being here okay right have a lovely
day or evening
[Music]
bye
you